it is fashionable and perhaps factual to
say there's never been a year like 2020.
a pandemic mass protest over racial
equality
a deeply divided electorate an upcoming
election
and more it is the latest challenge for
america the largest democracy in the
world and one of its oldest
this morning we highlight the authors of
a new book four threats
which takes a look at the stakes
involved both now
and over the past 200 plus years
[Music]
american politics has had troubling
trends that have been emerging for years
and i think for both of us we've been
trying to get our minds around those
things
suzanne mettler and robert lieberman
have been writing about american
politics for decades
for them the current moment seems
overwhelming
i would run into colleagues of mine who
study other countries in the world
and study the decline of democracy in
various places
and they seem to have more of an
understanding of what was going on
than i did and they would say things
like well you know democracies they come
and they go
they don't last forever and as a student
of american politics i was sort of
horrified by the idea that we were
thinking of the united states in that
way
mettler and lieberman's latest book
takes a look at what they believe
are the four threats to american
democracy
expansive presidential power political
polarization
rising economic inequality and racism or
nativism
in which direction are all these issues
trending right now they've all been on
the rise
the book examines how these issues
spiked alarmingly at different points in
our history
the first crisis right after america's
founding in the 1790s
when political polarization hit a
dangerous level
fueled by the warring factions of
alexander hamilton
and thomas jefferson the clash was
crystallized
in the whiskey rebellion a tax dispute
that led to widespread protests in
western pennsylvania
george washington sent in federal
soldiers to quell the violence
and was widely praised for it but not by
all
it caught the attention of a lot of
people that here you had this federal
government
that was using its power in a way
that most americans didn't think would
happen
they thought that was counter to the
spirit of the american revolution
what starts out as a policy disagreement
really almost becomes an identity
conflict between people who are
affiliated
with the federalists and washington and
hamilton
and other people who are affiliated with
the democratic republicans and jefferson
and madison
if you and i disagree about what the
government should do about something
that's normal that's natural that's fine
but when
that kind of dispute becomes
a matter of combat existence enemies
existential it's existential to like you
feel that deeply exactly
that's happening right now exactly
because you feel like you can't have a
rational debate about it
because you're so attached to one part
and both sides
saw each other as treasonous during the
1850s
metler and lieberman say we reached
another dangerous level
when the country continued fighting over
its original sin
slavery that led to the next great
threat
post reconstruction as the promise of
equality was pushed aside in favor of
segregation
america's first moment of executive
overreach mettler and lieberman argue
didn't happen until the 1930s
under franklin roosevelt when many of
his aggressive measures to pull the
united states out of the great
depression
came under legal challenges roosevelt
attempted unsuccessfully to expand the
supreme court to increase his support
the trend of increasing presidential
power continues today
has the expanded power of the american
presidency been a good or bad thing
it's allowed for the country to meet
unanticipated challenges and emergencies
in ways that were difficult to conceive
in the say in the 19th century but at
the cost
of giving a single individual a lot of
authority that he can use in in
ways that we might in the end not find
so
satisfying did the founders intend for
the presidency to be that powerful in
general no
executive overreach had a peak during
the nixon administration
when the president sanctioned criminal
activity to target his political rivals
from the 1980s on lieberman and mettler
believe
all four threats have been growing
especially political polarization
which they say hasn't been this bad in a
hundred and thirty years
it felt like a generation ago you could
have a political conversation
potentially at the dinner table but it
was going to be fraught
and maybe to be avoided but today
if it comes up no holds barred
it's bad immediately that's right and
everyone's intransigent about it right
yeah why we've sorted ourselves out
in all sorts of ways they say they wrote
this book to give americans a sense of
both how messy
and fragile democracy can be do you
think people should leave this book
discouraged
or hopeful you know i'm fundamentally an
optimist
so there's an opportunity here for
americans
to do something that we haven't done
before
and that is to find a way out of this
crisis
where we make the united states more
equal and more inclusive
rather than having a settlement that
excludes
some people particularly based on race i
think people sometimes think that
since this is the oldest democracy and
the most successful democracy that it
will always be that way
i think history teaches us that
democracies don't last forever
and that maintaining a democracy and
strengthening strengthening a democracy
is hard work
um one of the things that history
demonstrates is that there are usually
people who are willing to do the work
they don't always prevail in the way
that we'd like them to
but americans have not given up the
ghost
love that line americans haven't given
up the ghost great piece and i think
that everyone oh
you were kind of taken back by it but
no really i think clearly people are
hungry right now in this moment for
history
and trying to understand where all of
this comes from and i i want to ask you
are you hopeful after reading that
because to hear some of what they said
it was like wow
but yeah there's also hard stuff i mean
they deal with some very difficult
subjects but yes i think i mean i would
agree with
suzanne at the extent that you'd remain
hopeful but um but you don't know and i
think one of the interesting things they
do in this book is that they do make it
a little more accessible
um you know it's not a thousand pages
just over 200 pages
so you can spend a little time with it
and hopefully get some
some perspective on both the past and
and right now
all right jeff moore thank you